it's wednesday morning thousands of
pro-trump supporters
have gathered close to the white house
they've flown in from around the united
states
an hour later the man they've come to
see arrives
president trump addresses his save
america rally
in the ellipse the crowd stretches back
to the area
around the washington monument we will
never give up we will never concede it
doesn't happen you don't concede when
there's
death involved trump tells the crowd
to march on the capitol we're going to
walk down pennsylvania avenue i love
pennsylvania avenue
and we're going to the capitol they head
along
two main routes converging on the
building where the senate is moving
to formalize president-elect biden's
victory
twenty minutes later hundreds are
arriving outside
on the east there's been what they
called a save the republic rally
it now turns its attention towards the
building
i hope president trump leads the charge
into the capitol building
that would be awesome they break through
the barriers
[Applause]
at 2 30 they're into the capital itself
we're going in we're going in
back on the west side there's been a
bomb threat but the crowd
grows the pro-trump rioters breach
another security barricade
occupying the podium where joe biden's
inauguration is due to take place in
just two weeks time
another group smash a window here
the police try to push back the
protesters
but already inside the rioters have now
breached one of the pillars of u.s
democracy
by 235 they've made it to the rotunda
area
it's chaos inside the heart of the
nation's democratic system
agents move the vice president out into
a secure location
at 2 45 the rioters are in the capital
statory hall
leading politicians are now sheltering
in their offices
rioters invade the office of speaker
nancy pelosi
five minutes later and a group makes it
to the doors
of the house chamber inside agents
draw their guns and then at 2 59
the senate chamber of the united states
of america
is taken over crowds continue to roam
the corridors
for another two hours at 3 21 the first
report of a shooting
it happens here in the speaker's lobby
a woman is taken to hospital and she
later dies
extra agents are drafted in it's more
than an
hour before police say that they've
cleared trump supporters
from the steps of the capital and not
until 5
36 when officials say the us capitol
building
is finally secure four hours
of mayhem four hours in which the u.s
democratic system
came under attack from its own people